one of the things you actually have to
do if you really want to understand the
way that stars work he's understanding
what kind of stars there are and how
many of different types there are and so
on because if you're going to come up
with a theory of how stars form and
evolve it's got to match on to those
observations so you've got to do this
sort of fairly pedestrian activity of
actually just classifying the stars so
the the Sun for example is has its own
classification then the various
different classification schemes that
have been used but the one that's in
most common use nowadays called the MK
system is that the Sun is classified as
a g2v star stars are completely
different they range in size in the
amount of stuff they have in the amount
of density in what type of stuff they
have if it's carbon or oxygen and they
vary in temperature
the real problem in classification is
that generally the classification gets
done before you understand what it is
you're classifying that means that very
often in astronomy you end up with the
classification scheme which physically
doesn't make a lot of sense because you
just classify it on some fairly
arbitrary basis at the time it's sort of
a historical nightmare as to how the
Stars are classified they were
originally just you look at them and
depending on how bright they are you
give them a number so the brightest ones
were one and then they went fainter to
about five or six and then it got a bit
more technical technological when we
were able to look at a spectrum of a
star so if you shine the light of a star
through a prism and you look at its
rainbow you can see different different
characteristics of a star in particular
hydrogen and so a very sensible what
seemed a sensible classification scheme
at the science time was to classify all
these spectra according to the strength
of their hydrogen lines and various
other lines as well but mainly the
hydrogen lines and what they did is they
had basically an alphabetical sequence
starting at a working their way through
the alphabet where a stars were the ones
that had the strongest hydrogen lines
and so on BCD and so on down through the
classification scheme as the hydrogen
lines got weaker and weaker and other
lines got stronger so about the mid
eighteen hundreds is when this first
started happening it turns out that
actually physically this isn't a very
sensible way of classifying things
because it's actually it's a it's a
Goldilocks and the three bears problem
and finally Annie jump cannon one of the
first women who actually did astronomy
or is remembered for doing astronomy she
was the one who who got very
in the clarifications of these stars
when the way you get strong hydrogen
lines in the atmosphere of a star is
that you the star you know is hot enough
to kind of excite the hydrogen and then
the hydrogen then is there to kind of
absorb some of the Starlight and if a
star is too hot then the hydrogen all
just gets ripped apart it actually gets
ionized so the protons and the electrons
that make up the hydrogen get ripped
apart and there isn't any hydrogen there
isn't any uh nice hydrogen in the
atmosphere so you don't see any of these
absorption lines if the star is too cold
then the atoms are all in their ground
state in other words the the hydrogen
atoms just never get excited at all they
never do anything so they just sit there
they don't actually absorb any light
it's only a temperature somewhere in the
middle where actually hydrogen lines get
excited and you end up with these very
strong hydrogen ions so that's why
hydrogen you know the the stars that
have these strong hydrogen lines are
somewhere at intermediate temperatures
they're not too hot and they're not too
cold she kind of did away with the the a
through whatever letter it was because
she realized they were characteristics
that weren't just noticeable in the
spectrum but related to physical
properties of the star you can use the
same letters but you just need to
rearrange them so that they're in
temperature order rather than any other
order so instead of being ABCD the order
in which these stars come is OB AF gkm
so it ends up being OB AF g/km and she
just got rid of all the ones that kind
of repeated their properties and that's
not particularly memorable collection of
letters but it's been the reason why I
could just rattle it off like that is
because it's remembered by generations
of astronomers by a mnemonic where
little sentence remembering it I'll be a
fine girl kiss me is the traditional way
of doing it or there's other ones that
people have come up with as well
Oh be a fine guy kiss me and I think
there's a few other ones you can say
you'll be a fine girl kiss me if that's
your liking Oh be a fine girl or guy
depending on your preferences kiss me
and so I be a fine girl kiss me Oh BA F
G K M is the order in which these things
are then that's then ordered from
hottest stars which are the Oh stars
down to the cooler stars which are the M
stars the temperature basically
determines a lot about what's going on
with the star and the temperature is
correlated very closely with its mass so
more massive stars have generally hotter
temperatures and their atmospheres and
lower mass stars have cooler
temperatures and mass temperature has a
lot to do with how long a star lives how
bright is going to be what kind of star
it'll end up in eventually either a
white dwarf or a black hole well I
didn't I just change all the letters on
the stars why did they keep the old
letters it's because you get stuck right
you you have a classification scheme
when there's a whole bunch so there was
a huge catalogue for example produced in
the 19th century of hundreds of
thousands of stars had all been
classified by this scheme and so rather
than going through and reclassifying all
the stars the easier thing to do is just
to remember a mnemonic for the right
order to remember the letters in rather
than going back to hundreds of thousands
of spectra and reclassifying everything
the Sun is sort of a typical star in the
sense that it's in the middle of the Oba
g/km system 2g star and it's official
classification is a g2 v let's star the
the back end of it the V is actually a
Roman numeral 5 and all stars are
classified according to their luminosity
with luminosity class one things being
the brightest all the way down to
luminosity class five actually this
luminosity Class six which is a little
fainter and occasionally white dwarf
stars which were even fainter are called
luminosity class seven so the V at the
end is just telling you how bright the
star is and the other bit of it is
telling you about it effectively about
its temperature G is actually it tells
you that it's a it's actually somewhere
in the middle of the classification
scheme so the Sun is not the not the
hottest or not the coolest star it's
somewhere in the middle once you have a
classification of a G star you can even
classify it further and say it's a g0 or
g1 or g9 so g0 is are the hottest and
g9i the coolest so among G stars the Sun
is towards the hotter end so it's a g2
but yeah it's just the typical star it's
it's right in the middle of temperature
range right in the middle the mass range
it's it's not the most common type of
star because the M and K stars are much
more common but it's a typical star
since that it just sort of straddles all
the possible ranges that we know of
stars
the neat thing comes when you actually
start looking at collections of stars so
instead of looking at the properties of
individual stars you start looking at
collections of them so the first people
to do this were a couple of astronomers
called Hertzberg and Russell
so it's a very famous diagram named
after them so this is
very well-known chart it's called the
hertzsprung-russell diagram named after
the two people that used it so we have
going this way brightness so brighter
stars are at the top and we have on this
axis temperature and it's a bit backward
so stars get hotter as you go this way
you can see at the bottom they have the
classification the OB AF g/km and you
see this nice diagonal line here this is
what's called the main-sequence so most
stars spend most of their life on the
main sequence and this is where they are
while they're burning hydrogen while
they're fusing new chemical elements in
their cores and then after some amount
of time and for our Sun it's about 10
billion years we're already halfway
through that so we have 5 billion more
the the star will evolve off the main
sequence and become a red giant so for
example the Sun and its distant future
is going to turn into a red giant star
so it will cease being a V star a low
luminosity star main sequence star and
will become a giant star so it'll be a
luminosity class one or two and it will
actually get cooler as it does so it
will turn it into a redder star so it
will move down the sequence so it
stopped being a G star and probably
become a K star or even an M star